heures pour une demi heure voilà vous
êtes donc pu suivre le vote sur la
réforme de l'asile un texte que le sénat
vient tout juste d'adopter les sénateurs
se penche maintenant sur la loi notre ce
projet de loi est le troisième volet de
la réforme des territoires
le point de divergence important c'est
le niveau démographique des
intercommunalités
l'assemblée nationale a rétabli en
première lecture le seuil de 20 mille
habitants proposée par le gouvernement
mais le sénat en commission des lois la
abc à 5000 habitants
je vous proposons tout de suite d'
écouter la discussion générale sur la
loi notre madame la ministre est cher
collègue l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion en deuxième lecture du projet
de loi modifié par l'assemblée nationale
portant nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois qui
est juste à côté
monsieur le président de la version
sénatoriale aux collectivités locales
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs le rapporteur pour avis
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs nous est allemand cet
après-midi un débat important pour la
vie de nos concitoyens
avec la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république je les dis
déjà au sein de cet hémicycle il s'agit
de répondre aux injonctions
contradictoires des citoyens à ces
demandes paradoxal que le président de
la république a évoqué il ya une semaine
dans le rock de son discours à
carcassonne moins de dépenses publiques
mais davantage d'action publique et de
service public
ce qu'attendent aujourd'hui les français
ce sont des services publics efficaces
qui les accompagnent tous et à tous les
âges de la vie
les services publics efficaces aux côtés
de tous les acteurs de notre économie
tpe émergentes comme coopérative
agricole ancien ou entreprise moment en
est mort en difficulté les services
publics
if it up qui permettent toutes les
créativités toutes les solidarités et
tous les progrès communs pour répondre à
ces attentes nous le disons souvent la
puissance publique a besoin des
collectivités territoriales car aucune
des politiques publiques de l'état ne
s'exerce sans leur intervention
car ce sont nos collectivités qui
portent l'organisation des territoires
et la vie quotidienne des français bien
sûr en cette période difficile toute
action de l'état et les collectivités
s'inscrit dans une trajectoire
budgétaire contrainte dont sans doute
vous ne manquerez pas de parler au cours
de nos débats mais très magique et très
majoritairement par non malgré les
efforts que cela nous imposer que cela
impose à nos concitoyens je constate que
nous nous accordons pour réduire la
dette de notre pays pas pour répondre
aux sommations de bruxelles
et pour éviter d'avoir à faire un choix
impossible entre lesquels que déjà 44
milliards de remboursement de la dette
de l'état et nos engagements sur
l'avenir cela concerne les collectivités
vous le savez cela concerne nos
discussions à venir car la collectivité
ne peuvent plus dans ce contexte
demander des compétences générales forme
est dit
leur difficulté à faire face à leurs
dépenses obligatoires ensemble nous
allons essayer à partir de cet après
midi de répondre à cette double la
jonction nous écoute en avançant sur des
constats partagés et en construisant des
réponses d'équilibré j'ai bon espoir
c'est ma nature que nous y parviendrons
même si je dois le dire certains signent
certaines déclarations un peu difficile
pourrait parfois le faire douter
nous devons trouver un accord et nous
n'en sommes pas tellement éloigné je
crois c'est réponse équilibrée le
gouvernement il ya déjà contribué au
cours de la première lecture de ce
projet de loi il a souhaité pour ce
faire vous écouter ainsi concernant les
régions dont vous nous avez dit vous
même qu'il était primordial de renforcer
leur rôle je vous cite monsieur
delebarre le gouvernement et l'assemblée
nationale ont donné suite à plusieurs de
vos propositions
c'est le cas notamment pour les
politiques d'accompagnement à l'emploi
et dans ce domaine nous savons tous ici
les difficultés résultant de la fusion
anpe assedic qui confie à pôle emploi
sans distinction des personnels la
gestion des analyses à sion décidé par
et herman au niveau national et
l'accompagnement de ceux qui veulent
trouver un emploi se former ou se
reconvertir et nous savons tous que
cette difficulté empêche aujourd'hui le
débat sur une éventuelle régionalisation
de l'accompagnement vers l'emploi des
demandeurs donc néanmoins la suite d'une
discussion nous avons souhaité confier
aux régions davantage de responsabilités
en la matière
elle nous avons souhaité qu'elles
puissent disposer de moyens
supplémentaires lorsqu'elle présente un
projet ambitieux pour mettre en
cohérence est politique
concernant les départements ensuite j'ai
suivi vos débats en commission des lois
je ne crois pas me tromper donc le seuil
est en disant que vous êtes satisfait en
partie de ce qui a été fait vous avez
souligné alors que comme vous le
souhaitiez les compétences auxquelles
les départements tiennent beaucoup
notamment les collèges et les routes ont
pu être maintenues à cet échelon mais
j'ai noté aussi que vous partagez l'idée
de péréquation et de stratégie se
déployant à des échelles plus large afin
de pouvoir accompagner la montée en
puissance du bloc communal l'échelon
départemental se voit également confirmé
en matière d'ingénierie et de solidarité
territoriale
cette compétence que nous créons est
très fortement attendu et je pense elle
est de nature à rassurer les communes
rurales ainsi que les communes disposant
de faibles ressources
le rôle que joue aujourd'hui certains
départements en milieu rural monsieur
que le combat a été reconnu par vos
collègues de l'assemblée
et c'est le cas par exemple pour le
soutien à certaines filières agricoles
importantes et locales concernant les
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale je sais que vous estimez
que nous ne vont pas encore assez flou
je sais que certains d'entre vous et
s'ils estiment que nous ne leur donnons
pas assez de temps pas assez de
souplesse pour leur rationalisation et
leur montée en compétences je trouve
pour ma part que beaucoup a été fait
justement par le gouvernement et par les
députés afin de dessiner avec vous ce
que j'espère est un bon compromis
parce que comme vous le souhaitiez
monsieur bah nous avons fait en sorte de
ne pas déstabiliser les
intercommunalités récemment fusionné et
comme le demandent et vote rassemble
votre route assemblée de nombreuses
nouvelles adaptations étaient
introduites alors oui j'entends comme
vous la crainte exprimée par les maires
sur la disparition des communes prendre
26 mille d'entre elles en moins de 1000
habitants
même si on me disait je me dis que c'est
peut-être un peu moins de 25 milles mais
je constate aussi et nous devons avoir
le courage de le dire sur ces bancs que
le véritable risque pour ces communes
est de ne pas pouvoir répondre aux
demandes de leurs habitants ces derniers
aspirent à des services publics qui sont
souvent lourd à porter pour les plus
petites collectivités je pense par
exemple à la prise en compte de la
petite enfance
je sais également le besoin de
solidarité le besoin de coopération qui
ne pourra s'exercer qu'à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité ayant là aussi sans
doute le courage de le dire
l'ennemi de la commune ce n'est pas la
loi nôtre c'est la diminution du nombre
d'élus qui souhaitent s'engager souvent
bénévolement et je ne saluerait jamais
assez ici ceux qui ont permis une
amélioration si longtemps attendue du
statut de l'élu
l'ennemi c'est la difficulté à mettre en
place des services suffisants attendu
par les habitants
il n'est pas possible devant les
constats que je viens de dresser de
remettre encore et toujours à plus tard
des avancées indispensables à la qualité
des services publics
qui à la mutualisation d'ailleurs plus
je me déplace sur le territoire de
france plus j'en suis persuadé le sénat
lui même et parfois en avance sur ces
sujets de mutualisation notamment pour
les centres intercommunaux d'action
sociale
ce n'est pas à vous que je le dirai que
je la prendrai madame gouro sur les
métropoles
enfin autre sujet dont nous avons
longuement débattu l'assemblée nationale
a voté de manière conforme pour
l'essentiel les articles portant sur aix
marseille provence et elle a accepté les
grandes lignes du compromis trouvé entre
le sénat et le gouvernement sur la
métropole du grand paris les choses
évoluent donc et nous avons déjà fait
des avancées importantes vers ces
solutions partagées que j'évoquais
précédemment je ne parle pas de la
métropole de lyon pour qui nous aurons
quelques amendements pour peaufiner le
sujet il nous faut maintenant continuer
pour atteindre nos ambitions communes
améliorer le quotidien des citoyens en
réduisant les inégalités entre les
territoires et en remuant avec la
solidarité et des nos territoires en
remettant la coopération au coeur d'une
autre action publique redresser la
france
en prenant en compte l'ensemble des
territoires qui la composent ce
redressement
chaque territoire peu et chaque
territoire doit y participer car comme
vous le savez même si elles sont
indispensables à notre pays nous ne
pouvons nous satisfaire des métropoles
uniquement pour tirer de la croissance
des spas gérard collomb elles le feront
elles le font d elle ne peuvent le faire
sans les autres territoires sous peine
de produire des disparités trop forte
génératrice d'un grand manque à gagner
collectif vous l'avez réaffirmé cette
disparité trop fortes existent déjà
aujourd'hui entre nos territoires et
elles sont loin de ne concerner que le
milieu rural qui lui même n'étant rien
homogène
la seule étude des dotations aux
collectivités nous montrent sur ce sujet
deux choses que nous avons inscrit les
injustices dans l'histoire des dotations
et que l' hyper richesse continue de
côtoyer l'hyper pauvreté sans que la
régulation ne vienne à y remédier or
cette régulation doit naître aussi de
notre organisation territoriale et de
l'organisation de nos finances locales
permettez moi à ce titre de saluer la
mémoire de jean germain qui nous a
laissés un remarquable tableau de bord
pour réussir cette réforme et nous le
lui devant mais nous le devons aussi à
nos collectivités pour réussir justement
je vous propose de tracer avec ce texte
une voix mais deux voies vers un
développement plus équilibré plus
durable mieux répartie entre les
territoires et les citoyens que ce soit
pour la préservation de notre
indépendance énergétique
celle de notre indépendance alimentaire
ou bien la créativité et l'emploi une
voie vers des services publics présents
partout où ils sont nécessaires
mieux adapté à la réalité quotidienne
des usagers est davantage individualisé
pour l'accès de tous à la culture aux
loisirs à l'éducation au logement et
pour l'émancipation de chacun une voie
vers une démocratie locale vivaces car
transparentes ouvertes au débat et
acceptant la contradiction pour faire
société pour vivre ensemble pour que
chaque citoyen se sente partie prenante
de notre république de la construction
de son avenir et de celui de son pays
une voie vers une république qui
reconnaît sa diversité pour mieux se
rassemblent et tracer cette voie ce
n'est pas facile mais nous sommes ici
dans une haute assemblée qui aiment le
courage qu'ils rejettent l'immobilisme
c'est pourquoi nous pouvons et pavé uni
y parvenir pour ce faire il nous faut
prolonger la clarification des
compétences
vous l'avez dit monsieur venir ndong
c'est bien le sens du texte que je vous
propose
et c'est le sens du transfert de
compétence portuaire à l'échelon
régional que le gouvernement souhaite
défendre à nouveau devant vous et ce ne
sera pas facile je le suis il nous faut
dire clairement qui fait quoi
c'est le cas notamment aussi en matière
de tourisme un domaine dans lequel la
france à vous le savez un potentiel
immense mais dans lequel il faut
l'avouer elle peut encore faire des
progrès en la matière le gouvernement
vous propose de mettre fin à la che mat
au logis je pense que le sénat fort
justement peu friand la multiplication
des normes devraient applaudir des deux
mains et nous faut donner aux régions
les moyens de leur action même s'il faut
arrêter de se comparer aux länder
allemands qui gère entre autres
l'éducation dans son ensemble et qui ont
une absence totale d'autonomie fiscale
il nous faut donc favoriser l'adaptation
de notre organisation territoriale
diversité des territoires surtout
lorsque les acteurs locaux nous en
montre le chemin
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui encore
avec la collectivité unique fruit d'un
long travail de concertation entre le
gouvernement et l'ensemble des élus
corses que nous respectons bien
évidemment ici le débat sur ce sujet a
été transportée en les élus de droite
comme de gauche ont souhaité cette
collectivité unique et l'assemblée de
corse a approuvé à une très large
majorité plus de 80% des voix un score
dont on rêve souvent dans beaucoup de
collectivités
ce vote et a eu lieu le 12 décembre 2014
nous n'avons matériellement pas pu
disposer du temps nécessaire au débat
lors de la première lecture du projet de
loi
vous le regrettez nous le regrettons
c'est ce qui explique que les
dispositions portant sur la collectivité
unique de corse a été introduite à
l'assemblée pas autre chose
nous avons maintenant l'occasion d'en
discuter gardons pour se faire bien en
tête qu'il s'agit d'une démarche
républicaine et d'une démarche concertée
et nous devons nous souvenir que c'est
le choix des élus corses de voir le
travail sur la collectivité unique se
poursuivre dans le cadre législatif avec
le projet de loi nome
ils nous l'ont confirmé le 13 avril
dernier lorsque nous les avons reçus
avec le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve parce que l'organisation d'un
référendum reporterait trop loin à cette
réalisation
parce que républicains et attachés à la
démocratie participative
les élus sont les représentants de leur
territoire pour réussir nous faut aussi
construire de véritables espaces de
solidarité que ce soit dans notre région
capitale qui devrait montrer l'exemple
et entraîner la france dans l'ensemble
de nos grandes villes dont les villes
moyennes et les bourgs centres ou encore
dans les milieux ruraux
cette question de la coopération
intercommunale est fondamental pour
l'avenir de notre pays et de nos
territoires
je les dis déjà mais je le veux je veux
le redire encore une fois car j'entends
beaucoup trop à ce sujet de discours qui
sont j'ose le dire parfois infondées qui
vise à alimenter des peurs et même la
détresse dans certains territoires
j'ai le sentiment malheureusement que
les slogans circule bien mieux que la
recherche de solution responsable est
cicas les dames et messieurs les
sénateurs faut-il que je le disais que
le jeu roadies à chacune de mes
interventions devant le parlement
ce projet de loi reconnaît et consacre
la commune comme échelons de base notre
organisation territoriale
ce projet de loi n'entérine pas
contrairement la preuve à ce que j'ai pu
entendre au sénat où ailleurs la fin la
fin programmée de nos communes la
coopération intercommunale ce n'est pas
la mort de la commune
au contraire la coopération
intercommunale libère la coopération
intercommunale libère les plus petites
communes de leur carcan de leurs
suggestions vis-à-vis de divers
financeurs qui ne leur donne pas voix au
chapitre
elle leur permet de mieux répondre aux
missions qui s'attend du attendu d'elle
par nos concitoyens et je pense que dira
le contraire est parfois facile
l'intercommunalité c'était moyen pour
étendre des services qui jusque là
bénéficié qu'aux habitants des communes
centre ou encore des communes riches
fusse-t-elle en milieu rural c'est ce
que j'ai dit aux maires des petites
communes qui ont manifesté le 18 avril
dernier et à la rencontre desquels je
suis allé c'est ce que je leur dirai à
l'occasion du débat que je souhaite
organiser très rapidement avec les
maires ruraux
ces maires qui sont le relais principal
de millions d'habitants vivent hors de
nos vies les difficultés de ces mères je
les connais et je comprends leur
inquiétude
mais c'est précisément pour eux qu'il
nous faut réussir cette nouvelle étape
de la construction intercommunale car ce
sont eux et leurs communes qui ont le
plus besoin de grandes intercommunalités
vous en avez dressé un trait juste
contrat monsieur bertrand
dans votre rapport consacré à l' hyper
ruralité rapport qui fera date
alors oui c'est un pas substantiel que
je vous propose est que nous pouvons
franchir avec ce texte mais c'est un pas
nécessaire pour ne pas voir nos
territoires se déliter pour que nos
concitoyens cesse de voir des services
publics s'éloigner d'eux
pour que les territoires puissent enfin
faire ensemble au lieu de s'enfermer
dans des concurrences stériles qu'il ait
des cernes
nous savons tous le danger des
concurrences des dangers des
intercommunalités de défense qui assèche
en grande partie le développement de
territoires qui sont pourtant les
bassins de vie de nos concitoyens
c'est donc un pas nécessaire dans le
statu quo actuel ne peut plus perdurer
c'est ce que nous disent tous les élus
la situation aujourd'hui n'est pas bonne
et le sentiment d'abandon est réel nous
le savons et la loi est la loi et la loi
n'est pas votée que je sache donc ce
constat est lourd ce constat est
inquiétant pour nous qui espère ont
redressé tous les territoires de france
nous ne pouvons donc nous ne pouvons
donc en rester au diagnostic de ne
pouvant d'encore rester au diagnostic ce
ne serait pas responsable
le gouvernement a proposé un panel de
solutions mais rien ne se fera sans
coopération
donc oui c'est un pas substantiel que je
vous le demande aussi a voulu faire mais
je voulais dit chacun doit faire des pas
si nous souhaitons pouvoir nous
rencontrer et dessiner des réponses
d'équilibré l'âme et messieurs les
sénateurs
la nouvelle organisation territoriale de
la république repose sur des principes
simples cohérence clarté courage
coopération avait ce texte nous voulons
rapprocher le citoyen des services
publics dont il a besoin et pour cela
nous comptons sur les intercommunalités
nous voulons rapprocher les demandeurs
d'emploi des entreprises aider les
entreprises à tout moment de leur
existence
pour cela nous comptons sur la région
nous souhaitons faire émerger des
territoires moteur du développement
international de la france est dessiné
les technologies de demain
pour cela nous comptons sont les
métropoles nous souhaitons garantir la
proximité et pour cela nous ferons en
sorte que la commune reste le socle de
base de notre organisation territoriale
ce que je vous propose c'est de faire
votre des principes présentés par ce
texte de renoncer ensemble ici comme
l'extérieur de votre haute assemblée aux
formules parfois au mot d'ordre aux
lieux communs et c'est je crois la force
du sénat la force du sénat pour
construire les véritables conditions de
notre dialogue alors et y encourage
collectivement de trouver de bons
compromis là où nous savons qu'ils sont
nécessaires et sachant surmonter nos
peurs nos égoïsmes nos tentations de
repli bien humaine certes mais souvent
stérile
pourquoi nous citoyens et l'ensemble de
nos territoires puissent également le
faire pour refonder l'envi de faire
ensemble de nos élus locaux et de non
circoncis pardon pour refonder l envie
de faire société ensemble avec nos élus
locaux et nos concitoyens ces derniers
sont trop nombreux à ne plus voter et
donc à ne plus croire au progrès ni pour
eux mêmes ni pour le territoire auquel
il s'identifie et c'est sans doute le
signe le plus grave pour retrouver la
fierté commune est réciproque des
territoires de france ces territoires
qui ensemble font notre république
nous sommes ici au sein de cet hémicycle
des républicains convaincus que la
décentralisation fonds de l'organisation
territoriale de notre république et nous
sommes tous convaincus que nous avons
par conséquent des responsabilités à
assumer
faire en sorte que les valeurs de notre
république soit au coeur de notre
organisation territoriale souder une
société française souvent décontenancé
par les enjeux lourds du 21e siècle
redonner confiance au trop grand nombre
de nos concitoyens pour qui ce siècle a
trop mal commencé à nous donc de donner
sa chance à un bel espoir qu'ils soient
la foi partagée et réaliste et je vous
remercie de votre enthousiasme largement
exprimée depuis quelques minutes
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur s'il vous plaît la parole est à
monsieur rené vandierendonck co
rapporteur de la commission des lois
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
monsieur le co-rapporteur madame la
rapporteure pour avis mes chers
collègues comme le disait le premier
ministre le mardi 28 octobre la deuxième
lecture du projet de loi portant
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république offre aujourd'hui au sénat la
possibilité de jouer pleinement son rôle
de législateur comme cela a été le cas
sur les autres textes ayant trait à la
réforme territoriale que le parlement a
examiné ces dernières années le texte
présenté par le gouvernement
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
s'est considérablement enrichie au fil
de la navette
initialement composé de 37 articles
qu'ils en comporte à ce jour 166 dont 62
résultant des travaux du sénat soit 65
des délibérations de l'assemblée
nationale
globalement au terme de la première
lecture le texte qui nous revient de
l'assemblée a été amélioré tout en
respectant le travail et les apports du
sénat en première lecture ce qui ne rend
pas impossible une convergence tout au
moins sur un grand nombre de
dispositions notamment la suppression de
la clause de compétence générale des
régions et des départements
le renforcement de la compétence
stratégique des régions en matière de
développement économique la création de
deux schémas régionaux stratégiques en
matière d'économie et d'aménagement du
territoire ou encore le maintien au
département de la gestion des collèges
et des routes
mais des divergences subsistent est
importante avec l'assemblée nationale
car nos collègues de l'assemblée ont
intégré des dispositions qui avaient été
précédemment rejeté par la haute
assemblée dans le cadre de l'examen
d'autres projets de loi et je souhaite
bien sûr revenir sur trois d'entre elles
le haut conseil des territoires
le 19 décembre 2014 lors de l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles j'avais achevé mon
intervention en tant que rapporteur du
texte sur la question du haut conseil
des territoires
la création de ce nouvel organe
consultatif avait alors été ajouté à
l'assemblée en réponse à une attente
d'ailleurs exprimée par certains élus
locaux et associations d'élus d'avoir
une instance de dialogue entre l'état et
les collectivités puis à l'aune des
échanges entre députés et sénateurs
la commission mixte paritaire s'était
finalement rallié à la position du sénat
et avait supprimé cette disposition du
projet de loi
et bien les deux arguments de l'époque
sont toujours recevable
aujourd'hui d'une part cette instance ne
doit pas se substituer au rôle
constitutionnel du sénat qui assure la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république
conformément à l'article 24 de la
constitution et d'autre part la création
d'une telle instance de concertation ne
nécessite pas le recours à une loi
à ma grande surprise l'assemblée
nationale a réintroduit le haut conseil
des territoires cet article 1er bis a
été adopté il faut le souligner a été
adoptée par voie sans la part dont
contre l'avis du gouvernement est
d'autant plus que le gouvernement avait
mis en place une instance de dialogue
national des territoires notre
commission a donc supprimé cet article
un bis l'élection au suffrage universel
direct des conseillers communautaires de
l'ensemble des pays à fiscalité propre
alors l'article 22 au petit élargie à
l'ensemble des ep cia fiscalité propre
donc le principe de la fixation par la
loi avant le 1er janvier 2017 de
modalités particulières pour l'élection
au suffrage universel direct des
conseillers communautaires
ce nouvel article généralise à
l'ensemble des intercommunalités l'objet
de l'article 54 de la loi matam qui sans
même poser la question constitutionnelle
limitée cette novation au conseil des
métropoles
on l'a sorti sans d'ailleurs d'un
rapport préalable du gouvernement au
parlement pour éclairer le législateur
comme nous le disions au moment de la
discussion de la loi map l'âme il faut
le rappeler avec force le sénat est
favorable au suffrage universel direct
communal est hostile à la
supracommunalité
les conditions du transfert de la
compétence du plan local d'urbanisme aux
intercommunalités l'assemblée nationale
est revenu sur une disposition qui avait
fait l'objet d'un consensus sénat
assemblée lors de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi allure à
l'initiative de monsieur claude berri de
bas là aussi nous avions dans le débat
allure expliqué qu'il s'agissait pas
d'être timorés
il s'agissait d'envoyer un signal fort
aux communes en leur donnant à travers
cette minorité de blocage
l'assurance qu'on chercherait l'accord
et non la contrainte donc excepté ces
trois marqueurs idéologiques inutile il
me semble que les deux chambres peuvent
trouver des points de consensus sur des
thématiques majeures apportées par le
texte visant une répartition équilibrée
des compétences entre régions
départements et bloc communal dans la
logique du projet de loi qui est bien la
clarification des compétences entre les
échelons territoriaux le maintien d'un
certain nombre de compétences de
proximité des départements l'intégration
dans la loi d'une véritable compétence
du département en matière de solidarité
territoriale et humaine le premier
ministre ici même nous avait annoncé un
avait rappelé que pour assurer les
solidarités sociales et territoriales
entre les grandes régions stratège et le
couple communes intercommunalités le
rôle des départements seraient
importants je donne acte au gouvernement
de la clarification de l'intervention
des départements dans ce domaine grâce à
l'inscription d'une compétence en
matière de solidarité territoriale et
humaines à l'article 24 du projet de loi
se félicitant de la philosophie globale
de cet article votre commission des lois
à préciser les missions de solidarité
territoriale du département et sur
proposition de jean jacques hyest a
rétabli la voirie
dans les compétences pour lesquelles il
pourrait apporter une ingénierie aux
communes et aux groupements qui le
souhaiteraient réaffirmant ainsi sa
position de première lecture
notre commission des lois a également
adopté sans modification le schéma
d'amélioration de l'accessibilité des
services publics et a adopté avec
modifications
les maisons de services au public sur
les compétences de proximité du
département
là également la commission des lois
salue le dialogue fructueux qui a abouti
au maintien en première lecture au sénat
comme à l'assemblée avec le soutien du
gouvernement des compétences collège
l'article 12 voirie article 9 sur la
compétence voirie
nous avons tenu à l'article 9 c'est à
dire à l'amendement qui prévoit que les
régions pourront participer au
financement des voix et des axes
routiers qui par leurs caractéristiques
constituent des itinéraires d'intérêt
régional et sont identifiés comme tels
dans le schéma régional d'aménagement et
de développement durable et d'égalité
des territoires la commission a ainsi
adopté ces deux articles sous réserve de
modifications rédactionnelles il nous
reste et on y reviendra abondamment a
souligné qu'il y a sur la compétence de
proximité en matière de transport n'ont
pas transport interurbain mais
transports scolaires et transport à la
demande
il subsiste pour la commission des lois
une divergence d'appréciation que le
débat doit permettre d'éclairer et la
commission a également supprimé ce matin
l'article 8 ter qui propose l'évolution
des périmètres de transports urbains
dans l'attentes d'éléments
complémentaires du gouvernement qui
seront certainement présenté dans nos
débats clarifier les attributions des
départements clarifier et renforcer les
attributions des régions stratège le
maintient d'importantes compétences aux
départements s'est accompagnée de la
part du sénat du nouveau
honte et de clarifier les compétences
stratégiques en matière de développement
économique d'aménagement du territoire
est aussi d'emploi formation sur ces
deux points
deux principes ont vidé les travaux de
la commission des lois du sénat en
seconde lecture d'une part respecter les
équilibres qui avait été adoptée par la
loi madame c'est extrêmement important
respecter tous les équilibres
sauvegardés dans la loi matam et
notamment la partition des rôles dans le
couple régions métropole dans le champ
du développement économique d'autre part
et les 70 heures de débat que monsieur y
est a courageusement et assumer le son
sont là pleinement assumé je le dis
voyez je le dis sont là pour le dire
nous le sénat a insisté pour que le sat
et le sr2 y soient bien le résultat
d'une procédure de co élaboration et
cette notion de co élaboration
même si l'assemblée nationale a et le
gouvernement ont nom simplifié
pertinemment l'énoncé est très important
sur la compétence des aides aux
entreprises à l'article 3 les deux
chambres convergent globalement vers un
dispositif qui vise utilement à donner
une responsabilité prépondérante en la
matière à la région comme le rappelait
le rapport queyranne du rgam scène de
maele sur la question de l'emploi
le sénat en première lecture avait
attribué aux régions une compétence en
matière de service public de l'emploi
la commission salue les évolutions opéré
par l'assemblée nationale sur
proposition de la rapporteure pour avis
monique iborra néanmoins elle a rétabli
l'ambition décentralisatrice retenu par
le sénat en première lecture en matière
d'emploi elle a également adopté sous
réserve d'amendements le
de précision le dispositif introduit par
l'assemblée nationale
article 3 terres visant à confier à la
région la compétence de coordonner sur
son territoire les acteurs du service
public de l'emploi
enfin tout en conservant la suppression
de la clause de compétence générale
la commission des lois a supprimé les
ajouts de l'assemblée nationale en
matière de pouvoir réglementaire des
régions en raison des difficultés
constitutionnelles et juridiques forme
qui soulevait cher jean jacques hyest en
latin tandem veut dire enfin j'ai été
heureux et fier que le guidon soient
tenus par le président liesse car comme
pour la loi matam nous étions d'accord
sur la destination redonner au sénat le
premier mot en matière de représentation
constitutionnel des collectivités
territoriales clarifier les compétences
des régions et des départements
renforcer l'intercommunalité en
privilégiant l'incitation contractuels
plutôt que la norme unilatérale et
rigide et regretté la désynchronisation
entre le débat sur la poursuite de la
décentralisation et celui sur la
déconcentration
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des lois
la parole est à monsieur jean jacques
hyest co rapporteur de la commission des
lois
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il faut reconnaître que les
collectivités locales sont quand même
mise à rude épreuve
d'abord elles sont elles sont touchées
par une baisse sévère de leur dotation
est bien entendu comme depuis 20 ans on
a fait disparaître leur autonomie
fiscale qui se réduit à pas grand chose
pour les régions pas grand chose pour
les départements un petit peu plus pour
les communes et ben oui quand on a que
des dotations
c'est quand même ça n'existait pas je
suis désolé dans les années 80 et tout
ça pour des bonnes raisons
on a supprimé la vignette pour les
départements parfait on a supprimé la
part salaires ça a commencé de la taxe
professionnelle puis on a espère un
espèce de truc dont on ne sait pas de
toute façon ce qui vous tombe dans la
poche
chaque année la fameuse cvae parce que
je les dis monsieur je les dis mais vous
n'avez pas bien écouté
alors maintenant ils subissent des
projets de réformes institutionnelles
on veut installer au pas de charge sans
tenir compte de la réalité des
territoires et du sentiment d'abandon
des territoires ruraux et périurbains de
nouvelles intercommunalités vaste vaste
parce que ça fait bien
si ce quatrième projet de loi puis 2012
a cependant une utilité et rené
vandierendonck l'a dit c'est de
clarifier les compétences de chacune
d'entre elles enfin et oui jean pierre
raffarin avait essayé ça n'avait pas
donné de bons résultats puisque chacun
mais voulu garder tous à aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya moins de moyens peut-être
pourra-t-on espérer que les compétences
soient vraiment clarifier pour chaque
collectivité alors c'est plus important
à mon avis que de vouloir à tout prix en
supprimer des collectivités vieille idée
faisant fi de l'histoire de notre pays
aida volonté évidente des élus locaux de
mieux mutualiser les politiques
publiques vous avez raison madame la
ministre
les élus locaux ne sont pas sans vouloir
faire avancer les choses n'est peut-être
pas comment on leur propose je n'y
reviendrai pas en excellent
co-rapporteur rené vandierendonck que je
salue parce que il a plus travaillé que
moi on cherche du travail pour beaucoup
à voir définition c'est pas non non pas
du tout pas du tout mais nous sommes en
accord sur la conception que nous avons
des collectivités locales et je crois
que l'un comme l'autre nous avons une
expérience longue de faire vivre des
collectivités locales et de ne pas
théoriser les deux vivent
quotidiennement les réalités des
collectivités locales je crois que il
est bon que le sénat par tout ce qui
représente nos collectivités puissent
donner leur avis et surtout faire part
de leur expérience au quotidien
redescendez radical a dit ce qui
concernait les compétences essentielles
des régions des départements et
j'assisterai à mon tour quand même sur
une étape essentielle de la
décentralisation en matière
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi ce n'est
pas rendre service aux demandeurs
d'emploi que de déconnecter le
développement économique la formation
professionnelle et l'emploi ou
l'enseignement supérieur ça n'est pas
possible et ça n'est pas tenable on ne
peut que regretter je lis ça commence la
timidité de l'assemblée nationale sur ce
sujet il ya peut-être des marges de
progrès et au moins sera un aspect de
troisième étape de la décentralisation
le reste c'est simplement l'organisation
déterrer des territoires j'en dis
envolée communales et intercommunales
nous devons réaffirmer mais vous l'avez
fait madame la ministre que pour nous la
commune doit demeurer la cellule de base
de la démocratie locale et qu'elle est
plus que jamais indispensable si l'on ne
veut pas distendre un peu plus le lien
social est sacrifiée d'immenses pans de
notre territoire
on peut toujours faire l'éloge des élus
locaux comme ça de loin mais c'est eux
qui fige où ils font vivre la démocratie
locale et s'ils n'étaient pas là vous
croyez pas qu'il y aurait encore plus de
choses compliquées
comme le sénat l'a exprimé à plusieurs
reprises et je vous renvoie volontiers
au rapport
raffarin krattinger parce qu'on oublie
un petit peu ce qu'on avait déjà fait
mais aussi aux rapports belot tout ça
c'était dans la même continuité
d'ailleurs vous les 6 kg et souvent
madame la ministre je suis pas sûr que
vous ayez où vous vous ayez tout lu tous
les we meet our tenons nous rejetons
comme sin est l'idée de supracommunalité
et tous ses avatars en matière de
représentation comme l'a envisagé
l'assemblée nationale nous n'en voulons
pas
la loi votée par parlement sur les
communes nouvelles il faut rappeler
quand même dans les temps plus anciens
l'échec de la loi marcellin qui avait
fait une tentative devrait permettre des
regroupements volontaires de communes
mais ça ne sera jamais la panacée et
d'ailleurs on fera bientôt le bilan
puisque jour verra combien de communes
nouvelles ont été créées dans deux trois
ans cinq ans
il faut pas aller trop vite non plus
pour faire des bilans il faut pas
changer la loi avant qu'elle soit votée
quand même parce que ça arrive parfois
quoi qu'il en soit le test que nous que
vous propose la commission des lois sur
ce sujet qui a fait l'objet de tant de
réformes menées généralement dans des
temps assez long je vais pas rappeler
toutes les lois sur l'intercommunalité
que nous avons voté réaffirme le
principe de l'intercommunalité
regroupements de communes indispensable
pour exercer certaines compétences
ces communes ayant conscience de
regrouper leurs forces pour une
meilleure efficacité de leurs actions et
en l'espérant mais c'est pas prouvée
jusqu'à présent quelques économies
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas eu
l'économie bon
en relisant les débats autour de la loi
de 2010 moi j'aime bien relire ce qui
s'est passé si critiquée par certains et
si certains insistent trop je leur ferai
des citations notamment ce qui ce
concert le seuil des intercommunalités
mais aussi le rôle des préfets les
compétences obligatoires
il faut avouer que notre loi 2010 paraît
presque timide et rétrospectivement
équilibré et a permis après d'autres une
avancée considérable en matière
d'intercommunalité le seuil de cinq
mille habitants retenue alors a vu tout
le territoire couvert par 2134
intercommunalités ce n'était pas le cas
il y avait des secteurs entiers où il
n'y avait aucune intercommunalité à
peine deux ans après la création des
plus récentes voilà qu'on entend ans
qu'on entend diviser le nombre par deux
alors par deux parce que c'est
exactement ça pourquoi n'en sais rien
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'étude d'impact
sérieux sur ce que l'on en attend si
l'idée était confiée aux
intercommunalités certaines attributions
des départements à l'origine en les
délestant les départements fakoly
délester en les délestant des collèges
et des routes au profit d'un région
oublions cet épisode ce qu'on l'a oublié
sinon bah écoutez il aurait fallu
rétablir les conseils d'arrondissement
au moins parce qu'autrement ça ne
marchait pas nous voyons à proximité
doit d'honorer le maître mot de cette
architecture territoriale et l'assemblée
nationale
les mes collègues du groupe socialiste
ont bien compris en déposant un
amendement qui baisse le seuil
l'assemblée nationale a dû établir des
dérogations multiples qui certes peuvent
convenir à quelques départements hyper
ruraux
et par là c'est dommage
selon l'expression parce que c'était un
set de vous lui direz de notre collègue
alain bertrand
mais certainement pas notamment aux
secteurs ruraux des départements ayant
une métropole
une vaste zone rurale où une partie
fortement urbanisée le reste en zone
rurale non non non ça ne fonctionne pas
c'est pourquoi la commission ben non
parce que là on baisse le seuil on prend
la totalité du territoire je vous
expliquerai le moment venu madame
bourreau
c'est pourquoi la commission comme en
première lecture vous propose de
maintenir en l'état
en l'état le seuil de cinq mille
habitants en tenant compte bien entendu
des communes de montagne
ah bah non et les îles à cet important
aussi vous le fait aussi
oui des îles ah oui on va pas rattacher
une partie au continent dont l'île de
sein l'île de ré les deux secteurs sur
les compétences sur les compétences
cessons de charger les communautés de
compétence obligatoire même si nous vous
proposons de progresser dans ce domaine
je pense notamment aux déchets qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas être réglés
dans le cadre d'une commune mais de
nombreux problèmes vont se poser vous le
savez très bien madame la ministre pour
la question l'eau et de l'assainissement
laissons mûrir les choses s'il ya
volonté ça peut se faire
c'est des compétences optionnelles mais
cessons de mettre tout ça dans les
compétences obligatoires ça va
bazar terrible là aussi je pourrais vous
donner des exemples
grâce aux nombreux contacts que nous
avons eus avec des élus locaux et pas
seulement ceux qui s'expriment en leur
nom ou est ce que veut dire non
nous nous avons ressenti une commande
non mais
nan nan mais lui oui mais c'est parce
c'est pas tellement le cette association
qui regroupe toutes les communes de
france que je mets en doute mais c'est
des sous-filiales nous avons ressenti
une profonde inquiétude sur une réforme
dont ils ne comprennent je vous l'assuré
ni la pertinence ni surtout le tempo
infernal
chacun sait que la réussite d'une
politique surtout vis-à-vis des élus
locaux passent plus par la conviction
que l'autorité imposée et nous l'avons
vu dans la précédente réforme de 2010
c'est comme ça que ça marche et les
mariages forme et forcé ne sont jamais
une bonne solution
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre la
discussion générale sur la loi notre ce
projet de loi est le troisième volet de
la réforme des territoires voulue par le
gouvernement
tout de suite ses preuves par 3 votre
émission politique mais j'ai les crocs
sur et perrine tarneaud reçoivent
virginie calmels elle est tête de liste
ump en aquitaine pour les élections
régionales
l'optimisation fiscale et le sport
auquel se livrent toutes les grandes
entreprises dignes de ce nom
si on a construit l'espace économique
européen
c'est pour permettre aux entreprises de
s'installer là où elles ont envie
s'installer pour toutes sortes de
raisons et notamment pour des raisons
fiscales en toute légalité elle arrive à
diminuer leurs impôts de façon
substantielle aggravant ainsi les
déficits publics de leurs états
respectifs
quand les entreprises jouent à
cache-cache samedi à 15h15 sur public
sénat